[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like Brandon Shaw if you ain't
thick please don't get involved
now Brandon six boys
happy holidays
It's Beginning to Look a Lot Like
Christmas
everywhere you go
Christmas week kids it is Christmas week
I am at my wit's end with these damn uh
elves on the shelf I don't know when
this became a thing when I was a kid it
was not a thing but it is popping these
days
um kids love it kids absolutely love it
and every night you gotta move the elves
every night you gotta schedule not gonna
live stolen a few of your ideas
yeah dude that's what we do as dads we
steal each other's ideas to increase
your kids life
Jim robbed the picture here it's the I
rolled the elves into uh burritos Very
Mexican very on brand for my household
but the two elves are rolled up Mexicans
um
the kids get to name the elves that's
the way Elf on the Shelf works and it is
just a Phenom for parents
it's gonna put my wife and I have been
sick of this for years already girls now
12 and 13 this year the elf dies a
different way every day for 25 days dies
that's fun
uh this guy put my wife figures out what
to do with the elf every night so I get
to go out and just be surprised with the
kids kind of like when they open their
Christmas presents
hilarious yeah I wish I could I wish I
could uh just mail it in like you my man
but uh your boy thinks of some but I get
a lot of good ideas from other people
some some fans sent me the one of the
burrito one but it's spot on for my fam
the floor is lava it's interesting to
kill him every night might give the kids
some problems but that's way more fun
Elf on the Shelf wasn't a thing when we
were when we growing up yeah now it's
like a it's a commitment dude you got to
move them every single night
the one I'm going to do tomorrow uh when
these little bastards wake up is I'm
going to wrap the
their shoes in tin foil
so it's like they're wrapping their
gifts in all tin foil
so they really die no okay that's just
on that crazy dad was like yeah we mix
it up they're 12 13 so we make them die
for 20 days straight which is hilarious
yeah here's the rules don't touch me
he'll lose their power right they'll
lose their power so the kids can't touch
them uh talk to me I can't talk back
but I'm clearly listening write Santa
letter so I can bring them to him be
kind to everyone yeah it keeps these
little [ __ ] in line because if these
little bastards aren't good you don't
move the elves like dude bad sign man
you were mean to your brother so the elf
they see this and they're not moving
that means they didn't go back to North
Pole that's not a good sign more of
those it's just not gonna end well for
you dude my tiger writes notes and puts
them in the mailbox and the elves
supposed to take those in North Pole so
I gotta take them throw them in the
trash right but uh yeah if he's bad that
Letter's in there I'm like let's
see if the elf freaking went back to the
North Pole nope you [ __ ] up
it's like messed side again you know
[ __ ] up right you know you [ __ ] up
right you know you ain't getting no
gifts dude
you ain't getting no guests yeah but
it's it's a commitment parents if you're
gonna do Elf on the Shelf you're
thinking about you got a newborn out
there it just get your mind right get
creative there's a lot of ideas online
the floor is lava is fire that's an easy
one and then the the burritos super easy
one
it gets dicey though
if you really want to make it hard on
put the elves in their bed then they
can't touch the bed
you know something to do
but shout out uh I'll be glad once
Christmas night's over because those
goddamn elves are gonna be shelled for
an entire year it's a lot the kids get
to name them they name them chippy and
brownie I don't like the name brownie as
much as you guys do for the darker elf
they call them brownie
calm brownie all right like the dessert
brownie no I know where you guys are
going don't try and cancel my
six-year-old
my three-year-old the calm brownie what
do you want me to do dude
kids are crazy kids are freaking crazy
man uh your boys Chef Fresh Off The
the boat smelling like tanning oil and
protein powder I was at Olympia for my
friends at rain and rain uh body fuel
they uh flew the whole Squad out there
um
oh Thor commented on it uh I put on the
set for twins too here's the thing comic
right so I joke around clearly we're not
on a movie set clearly we're in rain
gear I can't tell you the amount of tax
I got from Friends
and other people going dude you're in
twins too that's insane I didn't respond
back but live your life Man Live Your
Life
but thorpo who's Danny I would be Danny
of the two of us you're Arnold Thor come
on dude figure it out I'm the smaller
one buddy Thor's such a good dude I had
such a nice time with him
the biggest human being I've ever seen
and I'm hard to impress Brian tells me
that I'm like I roll my eyes
Thor is the biggest human being ever
created it
big
straight up big dude giant man he's a
giant friendly friendly man
this loser put Aaron dot barrett.471
sounds like his life's going well but
wow an elite athlete and job nice no
[ __ ] dude I am not an elite athlete
that's why they should not have had me
in the competition but your boy did well
I saw before we get into him finally kid
well they posted us go uh or they
haven't posted I have this clip because
we raced bought there's like competition
we raced Baja trucks oh [ __ ] yeah that
was fun I have a dope video of that
where is Baja trucks pulled a truck your
boy finished third
be cool
um
that's the dead then we did deadlifts as
you can 225 60 Seconds
it was no punk
and then I did it with uh my partner was
that Justin minderos
I'm not in the CrossFit world uh so this
first time heard of him met him a the
nice kid in the world I think he's only
like 23. was a wrestler at Boise uh at
Boise State and the program uh left then
he was like I need something to do so he
got a CrossFit
um
he is uh
the guy he's the guy the guy
he's like Mr CrossFit two-time I think
world champion CrossFit Games young kid
him and his girl are super beasts both
are monsters Super Monsters really good
dude I didn't get time out there man
with all these Elite athletes and your
boy
I had a real good time uh but Christmas
is coming up you guys got done with your
shopping already
mark
big big Christmas Shopper over here yeah
I hear you
I hear you
I hear you so uh yeah so you had the
last uh UFC fight of the year you had a
fight night
um good card overall your boy watched it
from top to bottom so many decisions uh
on the prelims I uh was getting bored I
found myself staring at the wall for a
few of them
um my MVP of this
how many of two MVPs out my MVP would be
uh he's my favorite bantamweight doing
it right now that said nooga Madoff said
was getting
kind of out wrestled the pace this dude
set I'm not even trying to say his name
we'll call him his name said too said
Yuka Yoku Yoku is that right chin yeah
said Yokum said you was dude the Pacey
set was nachos and he was
all over uh Nebraska Madoff all over him
it was not looking good for him like
damn it says one of my favorite Fighters
although his dagestanian this dude he is
wrestling's not up to par like uh
makachev or
um khabib but obviously he knows how to
wrestle but he was just getting out
class out grappled the pace was nuts on
the feet he's so much fun if they in the
right matchups he's so much fun to watch
and I was like damn I was rooting for
him I actually bet on him and I was like
I'm definitely losing this and then he
gets him in that front ninja choke he's
losing an entire fight because my front
intro just tapped him out like God just
found a way to do it this kid is they
the real mother Trucking deal the said
[ __ ] Murdoch is a monster straight up
monster and this was not an easy matchup
for him this dude as soon as the bell
ran came flying across flying across
like Jesus Christ gave no space she
didn't want to get lit up the said kid
just spinning back gets spinning elbows
just non-stop so he wanted to close the
distance and dude his grappling was
insane the way he was would go to half
guard slice across the to side control I
mean it was a master class I was like oh
said screwed nope got that ninja choking
just wait wait for the right time and
got it done but he was in some trouble
there man he was in a lot of trouble
there
um Russell card okay you know the the
main card uh you got a few more finishes
there uh came out hot uh fight of the
night even though it only went into
Midway through the second Drew Dober
Bobby green
you know Bobby Green's uh
food truck alumni I was root for Bobby
green Drew Dober has been doing it so
long when I was fighting he was a big
name in the circuit the local circuit
Ring of Fire and he's uh he trains out
of Denver he's a Denver kid via Nebraska
First Team all dime piece that dude is
gorgeous but uh he's on a real winning
streak now I think his third win in the
row for 2022 Bobby Green's not an easy
fight Bobby green had a speed Advantage
hands down lighting him up Drew Dober
was eating him and just waiting to get
him against the cage
um I'd definitely say drew Dover lost
the first round it wasn't looking good
for him because of Bobby's speed
advantage and just mixing it up he was
giving it to Drew and Drew I think
you'll hear his coaches yelled Focus
because he seemed not focused he fell
into the Bobby green kind of games he
was like talking to him and it's very
unlike Drew Dober and then all of a
sudden he gets him against that cage and
they're trading shots and I think Drew
Dober is down to do this
saying listen I'll eat two of yours just
to land one of mine and show enough he
landed one he landed this right hook in
the exchange and it was lights out for
Bobby green lights out Judo is a tough
one the lightweight division because
nobody wants to fight the kid
now I can tell you this nobody will
fight this dude nobody it's knocking
fools out he's an excited one man he's a
super exciting fighter but Bobby green
Played with Fire and boy did he pay for
it I mean did you see it chin oh yeah it
was out cold you're so [ __ ] fast dude
Bobby yeah Bobby just light him up
they're not getting hit and yeah it was
Elusive and I was like yeah probably
just speed advance and then eventually
that Drew Dober bomb landed man it was
Savage this dude's going in there for
straight up
violence Drew Dober when he just signs
the fight he chooses
violence every time yeah the UFC's gonna
reward that this this dude should be I
think ranked in the top 15. even with
his style Michael dicey when he gets up
top but a Drew Dober versus Michael
Chandler
uh Drew Dober Justin gaiety
what
Drew Dover Justin gaichi take how much
you want to charge me literally whatever
you want to do
whatever you want to do uh Chandler
would be fun dear you should be fun
Gates should be fun poor Aid be fun
you know he might struggle a little bit
with the physivs of the world the
Charlesville levers of the world but I
mean Chandler Darius gaichi Porey fun
fight fun mother Trucking fight
these musty TV let's take a little break
fam from chatting your ear off about the
fight game because if you're a regular
viewer of any show I do let's go through
them Cowboys fight Japan Fight Night
flashback shab show
um food truck diary the golden hour
fighting the kid you'll see one product
one product only I'm rogued up baby
that's right I have them around me at
all times you guys know how much I love
Rogue nicotine I use their pouches every
single day I use them on my podcast at
the gym on my bike on the road in The
Green Room on planes there's no
restrictions it's fantastic the taste
you cannot beat I take it everywhere my
favorite flavor today I switch I'm a
wild man today is the Honey Lemon the
pouches I use the six milligrams a lot
of y'all using that three you need to
step your game up to six milligrams but
they got all sorts of flavors
Wintergreen peppermint mango Citrus they
got it all I love the apple as well all
right Rogue also makes other great
products products like gum tablets
lozenges however you want to get your
nicotine we got you Rogue is my go-to
source for nicotine for everything I do
I absolutely love them that's why I
reached out to them to be part of all my
shows if you want to try the pouches
like me or the gums tablets everyone get
your nicotine go to Rogue nicotine.com
use code rogue20 for 20 off your order
again that's Rogue 20
Rogue 20 for twin soft your entire order
of Rogue nicotine under eight sales
prohibited warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical for more information visit
rogue19.com Rogue nicotine baby this
episode of the shop show is brought to
you by on it and it's brought to you by
the best nootropic on the planet we talk
about Alpha Brain they're top seller I
like the Alpha Brain Black because
that's my little more concentrate
because boy has problems but even Joe
Rogan says it helps them form better
sentences you want to be more like Rogan
what are we doing here of course we do
you want to be smartest guy at the party
this holiday season you don't have to
tell everybody on Alpha rain and on it
so positive we're gonna love Alpha Brain
if you don't you get your money back no
refund necessary you don't have to send
the product back go ahead and keep it
give them about two weeks and then
return your money keep the product give
somebody who's actually gonna enjoy it
because you're a hater
it's fantastic it's the only trouble you
need to worry about you can trust on it
with everything supplements check they
got protein powder krill oil they got
freaking creatine Warrior bars protein
bites they got it all they also got
streaming Fitness on demand Fitness at
your fingertips don't worry about
getting a gym membership I go January
1st it's gonna be a thick Boy Summer
don't wait for the summer get your thick
ass going right now with the help of on
it you save tempson off the entire
freaking site the best nootropic on the
planet I'll bring check workout gear
check yep battle ropes steel Club Macy's
kettlebells check temperature off that
best supplements on the planet on it
check go to audit.com
save 10 off the entire freaking site now
seriously can we please get back to the
program uh Bruce Leroy got a great uh
head kick it was loud too in that quiet
ass Arena
um and then your co-main event could
easily be the uh Armin
Armin looked fantastic you know his
first fight was against mock Chevrolet
was introduced to the UFC and gave my
chest some problems
now our boy Josh Thompson absolutely
love will say well Mike Jeff wasn't
feeling good that day was sick I don't
think it matters Armin is going to give
anybody a tough time in the office
he looked fantastic
look at that first fight 2019 Fight
Night
was a unanimous decision of machichev
but he I mean he gave and it was fight
of the night he gave Mike Jeff some some
problems some big problems
the fight against camera could have won
either way Friday night too
he's gonna be a good one though physique
would be a fun one for him
I don't think they well they might they
might do Armin versus Drew Dober Trudeau
was ready for a big fight that'd be a
big fight that'd be a great fight
Arlington wrestlers tail off though
and then the main event uh it's more
controversy oh my God he goes decision
there's controversy yeah Jared Canon
there Sean Strickland
I think this is more of a matter of you
know Jerry can there against Izzy you're
getting there against a lot of people
he's just a tough cookie to figure out
he's just
he makes guys just kind of look kind of
basic or average or you know it they're
just there's something about Jared's
fighting style that guys just kind of
get outside what got them to the dance
and it creates kind of this boring
fighting style I'm not saying Jared's
boring I'm saying maybe because of his
pressure and his output you you it seems
to be your output's not as much even
though Sean Strickland was basically
trading one for one with him on the
output there but
it's just this chair Cannon air trance
he gets guys into this dance and it
doesn't make for the most exciting fight
so I think for Jerry can air Sean
strictly even though it was five rounds
um I had Jared win the fight I know Sean
Strickland says he was robbed I don't
think he was robbed
um just shows you to shows you the
judges just a complete disaster and
again you can listen to another MMA
shows everyone say you can't leave the
hands of the judges and we're just gonna
chalk it up as that right that's what
the fan base does we've been over this
last week in weeks prior where I tell
you that doesn't cut it for me but
you're gonna hear all the major Talking
Heads in our in our sport go can't even
heads of the judges man it can go either
way that just does not work for me in
this case nobody got robbed I don't
think Sean stricken was robbed I did
have deer can there wearing that fight
um
you know I would like to see Sean
Strickland wrestle a little more I I
don't think his wrestling's at that
level with those top dogs
um and stuff Jared's you know
Jared's had a good year you know he lost
to Izzy but outside that he's had a
great year for Sean Strickland two in a
row get knocked out and who's Jared can
there so I think he was seventh so he's
gonna fall back in the queue a little
bit but I think for Sean strictly let's
get back to his old ways and keep
putting that pressure on and
nobody got robbed that's what I'm saying
here no he got robbed but my MVPs for
the night would definitely be uh Drew
Dober and said [ __ ] Madoff
says were my ultimate favorite man they
just gave him a all right he passed the
test of the the straight up Grappler
let's let's get this kid some shine here
you give him the right match up he's a
superstar from Dagestan he's the one
dagger Stadium guy that can strike his
ass off he's so much fun to watch
yeah Drew Dober and said did the damn
thing then dear Canada got done Armin
got it done so overall
fun night especially for the last fight
I I would say do like a blowout
pay-per-view for the last one like last
one of the Year major prep stack it
major pay-per-view that'd been fun
didn't they do that before they've done
it they used to yeah they used to be
like in the year on a big note they used
to do it even after Christmas
but uh they've changed their business
plan so that'd be the last fight of the
year and obviously this show is
predicated off a lot of uh UFC majority
UFC because I'm UFC alumni so this shows
UFC heavy so we will also be shut it
down for this year so you have a shop
show today Thursday we'll do the uh
thick Boy network award show
um well announce all the winners there
and I'll do a quick recap of that on
Thursday and then next week for the shop
show will be off
first week we've had off this year man
so uh
before we get more into the show I just
want to say thanks everyone for liking
subscribing watching the videos
um following us on Instagram you know
thick Boy Instagram going from nothing
to what it is is insane man so let's
shout to the fans on that one
um you know it's a big risk for your boy
I left show timer at a cushy gig and
could have sat there and got my freaking
salary and just did my thing and not
worry about everything but uh that's not
how I roll so I decided to go off on my
own start thick Boy network and hire
staff and
you know I don't pretend to be the best
boss in the world but you know you only
can learn by doing and that's what I'm
trying to get done here and uh you know
there's a lot more that comes when you
start your own business things I didn't
think about and I've had people tell me
you know like even you know my friends
at Showtime Brian Daly and uh Louis at
malca and all those guys are like dude
you know it's great to own all your
stuff and do your own thing but it heavy
lies the crown man like you're not just
going to be the personality and the
talent anymore you gotta you're bossing
a match things like I can do that you
know I got it it's a lot man it's a lot
it's a lot because you're no longer just
the talking head like I was at showtime
and you know they would take care of
everything but now it's kind of on you
and
um I think we're figuring out the staff
here and
you know when I first started you know
it'll be I think it might be a year old
in January man
we're only a year into it you know so
um I remember the first day on the job I
called my dad and you know he's been
part of businesses you know for a long
time and I got the perfect staff he's
like you don't I'm telling you don't
you'd be the first CEO in the history to
start with the team and end with a team
within a year I'm telling you
something's gonna happen boy is he right
it's not the way it works you know some
it's not that people are about their job
it's just maybe they don't fit on the
team they're bet on a different team and
you know so doing that and having to
fire people or make decisions and figure
things out it's a lot man I love it
don't get twisted I love it just a lot
more work to my that's why it's a lot
more work on my plate you know you wake
up and you're putting out seven fires
buff and then forget about stand up and
forget about being entertaining on the
show before you guys even see me on
camera it's Biz brand right you put my
freaking suit and go to work there so
I'm learning a lot though and um yeah
I'm excited for an extra man because you
get the you know and that's why when Rob
Dyrdek came in when we first started
he'd he did campaign you know he knows
businesses is what he does Rob flips
businesses and does that he's like dude
yourself gold mine like this than this
and you got this and this is just my
head this is how much it's worth because
what's the goal I was like what he kept
saying even on the show what's the goal
what's the end game what's the goal I
was like dude let me just get to ten
thousand feet if this is a plane let me
get the cruise let me get to the Wi-Fi
altitude 10 000 feet and then I can look
down decide the goal right now we're
just trying to get this plane this thick
airplane off the ground and once I'm
starting to get there and we get through
the turbulence then I'll tell you the
goal but right now we're still in the
turbulence which you're figuring out I
think we have the right right staff the
right Pilots we have the right servers
nobody's dropping any drinks you know
what I'm saying so once we get to the
cruise control altitude Rob I'll call
you and tell you the goals but right now
we're just trying to work our way
through it but now this is possible out
the fans and watching and stuff like
that so I think we're almost at 160 000
Subs on YouTube
which is good YouTube's tough man you
know YouTube's tough and taking food
truck you know on your own and you know
shops you'll switch in from below the
belt formerly the big round breakdown
and then you have we toss in Fight Night
flashback which is a fun little thing
and then just doing companion on your
own you know I've never it was always
Rogan's thing you'd go and Rogan's yeah
I don't have to worry about [ __ ] ad
sponsors this that
different Animal Man different animal
went to your circus you know when you
start feeding the elephants and putting
together a show it's just a different
animal when you're no longer just the
clown dancing around it's a different
animal
um so it's great I love it it's just you
know we're working and hopefully you
guys see the work and
um for a year in we're doing pretty damn
well boys doing pretty damn well so I'm
excited for next year I think
everything's gonna get smoother smoother
and smoother we'll see what we like what
works what doesn't and then and that's
just thick boy that's not talking about
firing the kid in the golden hour and
the rest of the [ __ ] going on on top of
touring and merch and whiskey you know
so uh thick boy's doing well though I'm
proud of what we've built so far man I'm
excited super excited so shout out to
everyone this is all for the fans you
guys the reason we even have a job so
shout out to you guys liking subscribing
and
giving us your feedback and everything
man so and all the whole team I could
list everyone but you know so I'm gonna
forget people and hurt their feelings so
I'll just say the whole team so love
everybody involved and uh on I'm excited
for 2023 man I'm excited I can't wait so
thank you guys for paying attention and
watching and liking our stuff man so we
got a bunch more stuff in the works
can't stop won't stop I'm like a shark I
stopped working I'll die so here we are
but uh yeah just before we got into
current events wanna
give you guys a shout out the whole
Squad here everyone involved with the
show all the sponsors advertisers one
Championship UFC everybody man Rogue
Reign everybody uh on it yep the big
boys so I love you guys man so thank you
for giving me a job so here we are so
let's do it Jen sweet yes shout out to
all the fans
appreciate that I like your enthusiasm
that's just my personality hell yeah
dude you know no I love it dude [ __ ]
riled me up man you riled me up kid
[ __ ] dude I was like an Al Pacino
I was like an Al Pacino speech dude [ __ ]
yeah I feel like Rudy right now thanks
dude that's when I remember I said
bring out on stage Damon oh man how
about learning my boss Brendan Schaub
yeah when I was first headlined we my
age was like yo you should go to
Australia I'm like great idea in England
and we learned it was so much fun I mean
sure not so much fun but it's just me
and Chad it would be like an arena 4 000
people had you know I'm a year into
headlining they put me in [ __ ]
Australia so I'm not giant theater like
you have an Oprah I'm like no like just
you I'm like yeah so I'd go out cold but
then chin would have to get on the god
mic and be like ladies and gentlemen
you know him as my boss
give it up for bread and Shaw you're
like you're doing it way better than I
do yeah even that's way yeah he's like
hey everyone it's chin yeah Yours Truly
give it up for my boss
Brendan they'd be like is the show
starting there's no smoke or anything
yeah oh that's fun no but there's
nothing cold turkey
those are those are the training days
man you just do in front of a ton of
people
yeah we did Big Brown breakdown too take
some huevos man
that was a good time it was
all right so I know we're playing a
Europe trip uh on tour next year I'm
going through it right now mid Years
thank you
um
things like May that'd be dope
UK tour
Dublin cork all over London England
thoris I mean me and Thor spent a lot of
time together
um Thor's tell me to go to Iceland
never would have thought of ice he would
tell me it's like their favorite
that's me blowing my back out there
literally my [ __ ] came through my
jeans
what do you got chin all right so during
the fights I noticed the
one of the refs make a call in one sec
here so we're not gonna play this on air
but you could see this so I can tell you
what I'm talking about here so right now
we're watching the the Garcia
my shape fight and you say no uh foot
Stomps yeah which is legal it's legal I
thought it was weird at the time too
so I said that's not and someone on the
corner like it's legal right but the guy
had his hand on the ground which I
didn't even know this but I looked at
the Unified
okay where's his hand on the ground
watch you'll see in a second one he's
doing the foots oh see
ah
get on the rough
dude this he was just Molly wopping this
kid and this kid was like six six or
whatever the hell he was and there uh
this Garcia guy was just Molly just out
wrestling but the kid did land an elbow
the cut was spurted blood out he was
bleeding so much
so much and according to him so anyways
it is illegal if you have I don't know
the grounded opponent you can't stop him
yes I didn't know that so that guy his
name's I didn't know you couldn't need a
down opponent I I know you you can knead
of the thighs and stuff but I know
there's no
kicks the heads or knees the head I
thought why are why would why wouldn't
you be able to Stomp the foot it was
weird yeah I don't get it it's part of
the unified rules so if they're stomping
a grounded opponent well I guess that's
considered stomping you can kick all
right still kind of weird so that guy's
name is Garcia and apparently he lost 20
of his entire blood dude he was
wet it was so much blood yeah and it was
just right in the right place we've seen
worse Cuts in the UFC but it's just on
our artery and this thing spurted blood
and it was just like
everywhere yep and uh Cub I guess club's
one of his quartermen or coaches and he
said it took almost two hours to stop
the bleeding it was that bad oh they put
Vaseline on it and that thing would just
open right back up
yeah but he's fine now I bet yeah you
look good
um so okay let's go real quick on this
one so you already talked about Sean
Strickland saying he was kind of you
know like he was robbed essentially so
he's talking about the judges on this
one this particular card but the
interesting thing about this is one of
the judges who actually gave him the
fight is Sal de Amado this is
notoriously known for not doing well
yeah he's not I see I don't agree so
it's 49 46 across the board two for
Jared Canon there and then one Sal had
it for Sean Strickland yeah 46 49 to me
I have it you know 48 47. I had more 48
47. yeah for for Canada well we're all
watching basically in our own areas we
were talking about it was like a
sparring match like yeah both Landing
it's kind of weird I think that's more
of a Jared Canon air thing yeah so it
does that with a lot of guys in February
of this year Sean Strickland fought Jack
Hermanson and a lot of fans were upset
about the scorecards
with them because Saudi Amado didn't
give to Strickland all the other judges
did you know what I'm saying so the same
judge is the odd man out on both cards
so is this him trying to make up for you
not raps in football that you never know
horrible call we're like call touchdown
back and they see on the following Drive
they'll like do it just to make up for
like we don't want to be responsible for
this to do like a makeup maybe that's
what's going on yeah but uh it's just
weird that's the same judge the other
the show or scene yeah they're
ridiculous and this one is making a lot
of headlines now too so Doug Crosby is
kind of like a an interesting figure in
anime as far as judging there's a lot of
Fighters and coaches that don't like him
he has like a weird type of Personality
yeah I remember there was one fighter I
said I'm not gonna fight if Doug Crosby
is the job there's multiple yeah yeah so
since this happened uh so he judged the
Bellator Fight Before the UFC fight
right and it was like
awful our distance away yeah traveled
right yeah so he did it back to back and
then both cards so he Ruffians thoughts
versus uh sabatello oh let's see here
yeah this one here so everyone pretty
much got it for thoughts right but Doug
Crosby did a 50 45 for sabatello and all
these Fighters saying what the hell's
going on this guy's a weird dude
so since that since this happened the
back-to-back things with Patty pinbot he
also gave it to Patty paintwood as well
so people are criticizing on that since
they since this happened the California
commission is now having a rule if the
judges travel too far within a short
period of time they will not be accepted
on as a judge and they think that's his
I know they think that's gonna clear
them up because the distance traveled oh
thanks Commission
hey thanks for taking care of the
problem
thanks for putting a Band-Aid over this
insane huge gap in our sport
all right we do this guy's a terrible
judge you know what we're gonna do you
can't judge if you have to fly over 1200
miles yeah oh perfect thank you that
solves the problem thank you sir
we actually had a zoom meeting a few
months back this was something Nevada
athletic commission put together zooming
with a bunch of judges and a handful of
MMA coaches the job that was for us to
kind of sit down and bend some fences
and ask some questions things like
I'll be transparent with you guys the
number one outline in the zooming was
Doug Crosby like he didn't want to be
there he felt combative in the meeting
he thought I don't know
who's this talking Nick's sick legit
coach yeah I guess he was above this
meeting for us that's the way I felt and
not only myself but the other coaches
they were involved it's pretty evident
I got an idea
just get rid of him
yeah firearm let them let them do lower
level [ __ ] because the stakes are so
high in the UFC in Bellator and one
championship and ryzen he shouldn't be
part of it if he's this far off
multiple times yeah that Bellator one's
an actual robbery if you guys want to
look at a robbery watch that one scoring
that 50 45 the other guy you're out here
[ __ ] mind yeah
and then uh this is Nick's saying that
Crosby went to his gym later to tell him
how he like he wanted to essentially say
like what he didn't say on the zoom
meeting he wanted to tell him in person
like how I judge fights or something
like that he wanted to come to the gym
after I explained his version of judging
well you can't you're gonna Zoom meeting
with all your superiors why do you need
to come on your own to come talk to us
about what you see and what he feels
right in judging you have a platform
right then and there I let him in the
gym but I just left if you want to talk
to whoever you want to talk but I'm not
going to sign off on that I just took
off in my mind I was like maybe he's mad
at me I don't know yeah who gives a [ __ ]
Nick sick you know now is he gonna
judge against your fighters of course
that's what he does Welcome to the sport
and uh Mark just brought up this thing
about chel signing Chelsea essentially
was telling a story and he named a
character but he didn't use Doug's name
so interesting I do know uh which I'm
gonna call it
what the hell's his name Chuck
Mendenhall he wrote a huge piece on it
so if you go look at look at that piece
he goes through every detail yeah that's
great interesting
but yeah if a guy's this controversial
and judging just get them out of it
that's the thing so they're saying that
the athletic commissions they never ever
fire people they never let them go for
some reason they don't care because you
know why we don't care I care
yeah yeah who knows maybe he knows he
can get away with all this crazy [ __ ]
because he has something in his back
pocket huh thank God I'm not fighting
so I wasn't aware of this but John
McCarthy's son was one of the judges for
The Patty pimbler fight and he gave it
to pimplete too I saw John McCarthy tell
someone you got it wrong he's a Savage
yeah no [ __ ] way Patty won that fight
McCarthy said on his weighing in podcast
security my son was one of the judge he
asked me and I said you gotta wow you
got that wrong I thought your uh Gordon
won 29-28
um first round the fight you're going to
hit Patty uh piglet with left hook like
it was a magnet hit him over and over
and over yeah that left that left hook
was Landing he stung him you could see
it now Patty has his things but this can
happen when you're judging Center you
get getting uh the crowd respond every
time Patty does something because
truthfully pay did not punch as many
times as Jared Gordon ah the comic
strike numbers back to Dipper uh he
didn't land as much as Jared Gordon
again copy strike
but I mean ultimately he's saying that
his son was probably swayed by the crowd
exactly that's I've always said this
this is why the judges should not be in
the arena they should be in a
undisclosed location watching seeing how
we do because when you're cage side you
can't see everything they should be on a
not in front of a live crowd somewhere
else
scared the travel issue yes take care of
the travel issue that they're all
worried about just have them in Vegas
but outside of the arena in some
undisclosed area you know so they're not
swayed by the judge they're swayed by
the crowd and all the exciting and all
that [ __ ] just like a the UFC production
truck type of thing just being a truck
or something put them in the truck uh
that's a son by the way
okay your boy Jake Shields
him and Mike Jackson who's also the
journalist slash fighter foxy and punk
uh they've been having some issues I
didn't know this but so they hate each
other apparently so Mike Jackson calls
well don't say the word you know the way
the algorithm algorithm doesn't
understand how to use the word in
context so but you know this is the word
uh names with Roti yeah
and then yeah
so and as far as I know I'm filming on
the the Gap in my story Mike Jackson
referred to Jake Shields as a roti Jake
seal Jake Shields kept like coming at
him saying you know
he's basically racist yeah and like he's
this whoa kind of you know
far left us or whatever I think
um
so then eventually they kept going at
each other and then Jake was like one
shot to the pi
and Mike did right like I don't know if
they meant to meet each other there but
they saw each other there now I would
say this if Mike did mean to say because
it's so easy to talk [ __ ] to any
professional fighter
listen Mike Jackson compared to Jake
Shields it would be a normal pre he's
just a journalist compared to Jake
Shields credentials in his fighting
history like Jake Shields as real as
they get right so for Mike Jackson who's
a reporter one foot in one foot out
compared to Jay could be just your
normal guy
but I will say this for it's so easy to
talk [ __ ] somebody behind a you know a
cat profile or meme or whatever the hell
you are and your real name's not
attached to it because you know there's
no consequences so what I respect out of
Mike Jackson is again I don't know all
the details so many people like dude
you're wrong this random each other but
for him talk [ __ ] and then actually try
to back it up
respect
respect no one would ever do most of
them 99.999 these haters would never say
anything in your face
I respect my guy I have some balls
because
Jake Shield definitely a better fighter
in every category every facet of this
fight game Jake Shields is you know Hall
of Famer Mike Jackson is not Mike
Jackson's a good reporter good
journalist also kudos to Hanford even
jump in there to take fights badass dude
fighting CM Punk badass right
so for him to talk all that stuff and
then actually show up
against a guy if no DraftKings doesn't
do odds on the street fight but you're
probably a plus 40 000. this isn't gonna
go your way so good for him uh from what
I heard uh you know Jake took him down
Mount them beat the [ __ ] out
yeah so I heard that well according to
Mike Jake saw him at the pi
that he spit at Mike and then they kind
of went at it I think Mike threw a punch
and then Jake took him down yeah this is
the video he got it's a cell phone video
[Music]
huh
can somebody get this [ __ ] on
you
CJ gets mounted there that's you know
they're lucky they stopped that like it
could have got very he wasn't even
trying to like really get at him because
he was still open hand slash and stuff
now the the problem is is this is
assault Brother so uh I would assume
that that
ippi Pi they're probably gonna press
charges
yeah I guess he has business there he
has like you know uh Fighters there as
well as Jake does yeah so I think he's
right now I think he's banned yes like
suspended at least and I'm pretty sure
the president charges which is a bummer
that would suck because
also
I mean you don't want fights out that
you're you know their headquarters stuff
like that
but you think of any business the world
the UFC will go I get it
and also
two professional fighters
one's talking [ __ ] they're running each
other that's what happens you know they
said they wanted to go to the cage and
fight too that's been cool yeah I'd pay
for that but it's you know you can't do
it there
all right
um but talk [ __ ] you're gonna find out
yeah at least
they actually got together
backed each other's up backed each other
up so
uh so this guy Orlando Sanchez who went
viral on that video Yeah Sean Strickland
40 years old it's so funny it was viral
in the video again trying to streaking
inspiring with him but he was the 80cc
world champion Savage Savage 180cc
monster and the guys he beat to become
Champion Savage
do we know what he passed away no so I
try to like look online and then all I
saw was this that his family is saying
that they're you know they want to keep
their pride the privacy and they they
turned on the notion that he was shot
to death
like I guess there was a rumor going on
that he was actually shot
[Music]
heartbreaking yeah
40 years old yeah family thinking of
three kids horrible
um I can't play this well I can play it
for you but this is my Marius
pujianowski who was like the World's
Strongest Man and uh fighting Mohammed
Khalid off and he got he actually tapped
the strikes
you know show you here
God poochows he's still jacked and that
guy just tossed him
foreign
get me out of here
good for him yeah
okay this one's a little political so
this happened after the Paddy Pima fight
Justin gate she posted something on
social media about Barstool right
because this is when uh Dave Portnoy was
walking up to Patty pimple after they
won
so this well you want to play the video
real quick
sure all right
this is on Twitter so it should be fine
so it's after the fight yeah so fortnite
and Marshall and kahoots together and
then they they also represent
Patty pimlet they sponsor him
Patty Perry was calling for fight at
night which is no yeah absolutely
nothing so then this is what Jessica was
Justin so he's saying this makes the
Marshall guys look really bad just bend
over for the lad fight of the night bars
we're gonna give him 50k but that's that
performance will never get you a bonus
in the Octagon argue with Justin that
it's not fighting the night but then
Dave does this Dave's a Savage so just
in case you be careful what you asked
for Dave lives for this stuff Dave goes
people tell me just get you was recently
seen hang out the ward low War load
warlord accused of brutal crimes against
humanity so it's hypocritical for him to
say we look bad for supporting Patty
when he Sports a war Lord I'm gonna take
the high road plus not mention it
hashtag Dave High Road even though you
mentioned yeah and then this is how
Justin responded that's an outright lion
slander Dave's a [ __ ] yep and then also
lastly the salary uh never met the guy
go [ __ ] yourself but isn't there a
picture of Justin yeah so he's just
engaging the guy from uh so the guy's
name is
[Music]
yeah yeah he's like the head of
chechnya right but anyways he's like
he's definitely a warlord he's attached
to multiple murders tortures all that
stuff and with gay people he heard what
he did he was like
he wants gay family members of gay
people to kill them so as an alternative
of you know law enforcement killing them
you even let gay people out of prison
early so that the thing gets their
family members and then get killed Jesus
he's really [ __ ] up so then there's
just engage you there so Justin gaichi
was there to for his son's birthday but
not necessarily for him but that's
basically the same thing yeah
she's not gonna win this war yeah
yeah so this got so much attention that
um
the U.S state U.S department state which
is uh their their federal government for
foreign policy foreign relations they
actually made a statement about it
right here
sponsor who don't get your newsman's
visit they all have the same manager
right Ali so
uh tour instruction statement MMA junkie
reiterate that the U.S citizens should
not travel to Russia and those in Russia
depart immediately a Russia travel
advisory means that level four do not
travel due to a number of factors
including the unprovoked and unjustified
invasion of Ukraine by Russia's military
forces the potential for harassment of
your assistance by Russian government
security officials the slinging out
singling out singling out of U.S
citizens Russia by Russian government
security officials including for
detention arbitrary enforcement of local
law limited flights into and out of
Russia and the embassy limited ability
to assist U.S citizens in Russia Yeah so
basically if you go there they can't
it's on you yeah look what they did
Brittany Greiner do mm-hmm
and this is I don't know why those guys
are going out there I mean how much cash
are they they ain't worse so Sean and
Molly was invited too I guess he implied
that it was 150k that they got paid it's
a lot of money
but he didn't go I would go just kidding
I know I would uh
I promise y'all wouldn't go no that'd be
too scary man you never know
but he'd end up going because he found
out you know that guy is like best
friends of Putin he's a bad dude
but he said if you need money like this
is the last thing I said about Henry
sagudo was kind of funny
you're broke and someone offers you 150
000 I bet Henry jumped all over it he
probably said I'll do it for 150 100 000
and a [ __ ] quesadilla
quesadillas unnecessarily yeah why bring
the quesadilla into it sugar
yeah I wouldn't do it that's a bad idea
yeah pros and cons
Pros you get 150k you hang out and shoot
guns with his kids over this horrible
warlord's son
Khan you get your 150k they take it at
the border and get trapped there like
Brittany Greiner
nope too scary not worth it
even so I was talking to Cowboy about
you know you got his hair done yeah in
Turkey in Turkey I guess they offered
him like you know pain medicine so that
he wouldn't feel all the egos [ __ ] that
I don't know what's in there what if
they do something to me and then he
sleeps they do [ __ ] so he's like [ __ ]
that he stayed awake and had all the
pain because he doesn't trust that which
I would be too if you're in a different
country
for everybody involved I saw this from
Luke Thomas or boy and I'll just play it
real quick because this is his Instagram
different country obviously he said that
he's out of the usada testing pool you
get out of the testing pool and if you
want to get back in to go fight you have
to declare anything you took you have to
be in the testing pool for six months
but here's the catch the people remove
them from the rankings we've asked USANA
for comment they did now they don't
really tell us anything I saw this post
and I was like yeah that's crazy it
didn't and then suddenly later I saw
reports of him being removed from the
right attention so I wonder I wonder if
people like I remember there was like a
journalists asking questions about the
usada thing with Connor to Dana and no
one knew he wasn't getting tested he was
still rankings he was still in the
rankings so I wonder if no one really
caught on if conquered just come back
without having to do the six months hey
what up yeah yeah until now yeah he puts
the UFC under the spotlight they
probably aren't going to let it I bet
you they still do
exemption but they do
they'll figure way out around it
maybe maybe could open the UFC lawsuit
even that's not worth it even as much
Conor brings in it's going to open up
the lawsuit yeah it's not gonna help
it's actually going to help uh Mark
um
Mark Hunt's case
oh yeah
oh [ __ ] I have a thing about Marcon too
later but so basically this this uh
thing that Luke is talking about is you
know taking the medication for the his
injury he goes he's for it like Luke
agrees at that thank everybody for the
most part your boy TJ uh when he was on
your show MMA junkie said this too but
TJ's saying the same thing like just
just to heal up from that especially
that crazy injury of an injury
I don't have a problem with it
alrighty um
let's go
oh yeah this is silly but I don't know
if it's true or not Conor McGregor
posted that he was 100 going up to
middleweight at some point I doubt it
it's fun to talk about but doubt it yeah
for him
all righty so this was interesting I
guess remember talking about uh Korean
zombie like he got an injury he was
supposed to headline into Korea yes
since he got injured they're gonna move
the entire event they're not going to
Career anymore right they're gonna
postpone it and then uh Derek Lewis
versus Sergey Spivak which was supposed
to happen earlier but Derek got injured
or sick uh they're gonna move that to
Las Vegas for about an event Friday
night yeah I'm not mad at it
and that's going to be February 4th
um here's a quick one Marvin Victoria
versus Roman delizae and this is
Marvin's record right now
he just lost Whitaker but he beat Costa
yeah and this is the guy he's fighting
who's legit yes very 12-1 not an easy
fight yeah at all in any capacity
and another quick one Cody garbrap
versus yeah Cody's back Cody so he's
been having a rough patch right now
one two three four five five out of six
yeah yep and then here's his opponent
it's kind of like it's a good matchup
I'd say yeah I'm not mad at it yeah
um
this could be saying something about
makachev having about five or six title
defenses and then the sport will
eventually catch up to him so he should
he said like he should do five or six
and bounce and then people are taking
that as like oh you you don't think he
could do more it's kind of a weak way of
thinking yeah he can't get better you
can't adapt but he was saying like
nothing people can catch up with this
style so so let me get this straight
yeah I'm with people on this like to be
backed out right so if a guy did come
who can wrestle and negate mucho's
wrestling could be wrestling you just
retire
he said before he gets beat retire
that's stupid but that's how many
champions do so he's saying something
like I'll play this you just you could
read it
six defenses six fights three years
then it's possible for the sport to
leave him you can't stay on top forever
and then he says the way Almighty
created man is first become strong then
weak
he's young then he's old
yeah yeah I think maybe what he's saying
he should have said in the sport past
him like then because fires get better
it's just like
he should do as many title defense as he
can before Father Time catches up to him
you want to say the game catch that
thing it's like hold up so if somebody
comes along who poses a thread he just
retires that's some weak [ __ ] right yeah
uh this one so
Chelsea is getting sued by an employee
of that Four Seasons Zone like a
maintenance man he says that he punched
him in the face
in the jaw I thought this thing was I
know but that that's another person now
outside of that couple
so he has to deal with that right now
they mentioned you in this article too
what um what did I do oh I guess the
couple
we're responding to what you to the
review journal about something you said
so it says the step Flags told the
review journalists over concussions
Julie suffered a split lip in the ledge
attack which they call tolion provoked
and responsive podcaster Brent Schaub
claimed that soon to defend his wife
Brittany after some drunk guy insulted
her
yep standby
okay so Brandon Moreno as you know his
coach was James cross but he cannot be
part of that anymore because James
krause's new sir under investigation I
heard that thing is just getting
underway it's supposed to get pretty
dicey insane so he teamed up with safe
south from uh four to seven May which is
a great team
oh yeah it's a young kid on there ralla
roses Jr yes the little badass
good for brown Moreno that'd be good for
him
here is a short little thing here this
this is just Sean O'Malley talking about
so sugar says I want to fight in july at
DeLay So aljo and Harry need to fight in
March not April hustle up then uh I'll
I'm sorry and then Henry Theodore
responds hey Suga should fight Patty the
judge won't know who to Rob
hilarious yeah Savage then there's so
who in the comments but got him
yeah so who does give me a prom for all
them boys here's a quick footage this is
like sparring footage of uh tuivasa and
your boy Mark hunt
all right
Jesus I mean
I know who's this who's to say then boys
did it right they just got them
Polynesian thick skulls different
and someone
pointed that pointed this out to me I
forgot his name [ __ ] but um
this is Street beefs
and I'll just play this part
[Music]
yeah we definitely know who it is
kids shout out my family I love y'all so
much hell yeah hey shout out am I
supposed to be shuttle premium clothing
line check them out and then I have a
thick boy clothing line check them out
for all for all big guys fluffy guys
whatever man we got comfortable clothes
for you what it must be a different
thick boy but I don't know this thick
boy clothing sounds just like thick boy
clothing that you own yeah if it ain't
with three C's it ain't [ __ ]
I don't think we have anything to do
with this guy but just like the guy in
uh
rough and rowdy guys which I still gotta
send them some money we need to get this
hey if if you're the trapzilla uh DM me
man I guess things have money for
putting big boy on your shorts even
though we didn't ask you to do it I
appreciate it
don't so anyone knows him hit him up let
him know I'm looking for him
okay
oh this is cool so Ryan Garcia is
training with Penner Jiu Jitsu and the
gitu
and Hunter putt day one how long do you
think it takes uh at King Ryan to reach
the black belt 10 years
let's get everybody else 10 years but at
Hannah and uh huron's Place probably 15.
they like to go a little slower trust me
that's great he's learned that though
yeah that's cool
this was I thought I don't know how old
this is but it's a cool stat oh I saw
this Drew dobre was knocked down for the
first time in his UFC career this year
on his 18th appearance in the promotion
this is nuts there's currently three
fighters in the UFC with 20 plus
appearances that have never been knocked
down or stopped by strikes
so it shows Max Holloway 26 fights even
fighting 11 years never knock down Jon
Jones 22 fights 14 years never even
knocked down then our boy Cheeto Vera 20
fights been fighting for eight years
never knocked down crazy
Jones the most impressive because he's
fighting at a heavier weight that's not
so dude nuts nuts nuts and the way Max
Halloween Cheeto fight to never get
knocked down is insane yeah
um I can't play this [ __ ] we'll just
skip this one
oh did you agitate [ __ ] somebody up yeah
it's pretty dope though you know let's
just watch it
so this is him uh
so this hater was just calling talking
[ __ ] to him showed up he's haters man
hater can actually fight too
laughs
did you throw kicks no
no just block
[Music]
the haters breathing heavy
[Music]
Tate's barely moved his movement there
is weird but he's just messed up
[Music]
yeah
great body shot there oh that hurt him
that hurt him
four
five
five
yeah oh
this one hands up Focus
Focus okay let them up
good for Tate yep hey what's taking
these on them too all right is this this
looks like a like a a freaking Hilton
workout space
or just his house Radisson in yeah
good for him yeah and this is Terence
McKinney I thought this is hilarious
Terence bikini wrote the Schmo pieced up
Jake Paul dude when I saw something oh
[ __ ] and Jake Paul fighting it looks he
throws the spinning back fist yeah
wobbles the [ __ ] up watch this whoa
so it looks like him though the Shmo and
Jake Paul
11 million views
so funny
um this is Sean Strickland in 2014.
dying yes
when he fought uh Ponce Nivea wow
American he looks like Italian yeah the
stud good looking kid Miss here's
fantastic I know he doesn't grow back
out
and let's end on this one yes please
okay so Christian you know Christian Lee
her sister sisters Anjali so Christian
Lee he's the double champ welterweight
lightweight Angela Lee She's she almost
was a double trip I think she still won
that fight me too she's still a champion
Adam what do you think oh I'm a thick
boy but yeah okay and then so this is
their little brother who's a two-time
pancreation world champion right
and their other sister Victoria she's
the youngest right she's the honest she
became Pro and she won all three of her
fights by finish Jesus Christ this
family family dude they're all good
looking people yep chill out
yes sir and that's pretty much that's it
oh wait here's Georgie's fight I don't
know we're it's a little too early to
announce this but it's not too early
announcements
we're not doing the show either yeah the
double George's are uh they've been in
that uh
Ulta fight uh camp for over 20 weeks now
getting ready to go so it is going down
I love how they don't have the date on
there it is going down was it January
7th it is January 7th 5 p.m 5 p.m
January 7th of the Commerce Casino in
Commerce Casino California damn it has
its own City Commerce Casino California
that's off 6131 Telegraph Road your boy
keto George is fighting and also tall
George is fighting two thick boy
employees are fighting in this Alta
thing
um and they've worked their ass off man
I've seen a complete change and
especially keto George remember
kilojore's story this is a kid who
called in the king in the sting also
known as the golden hour he called into
that what two years ago and he was like
400 pounds and he just loved him at
First Sight and said I'm gonna get down
to 190 the year down to 190 I'll fly you
out here put you on the show he goes all
right say less worked his ass off gets
down to 190.
I fly him out he comes on the show he
wrestles Stevie weeby I said what are
you doing this weekend uh nothing let me
look at my schedule nothing I said cool
I'm bringing to San San Antonio uh doing
a show out there so I bring him there I
put him up at my favorite hotel hotel
Emma they give him the presidential
suite and then after that
um he asked to be internet thick boy he
was the intern here for 30 days and now
he's a full-time employee and he is a
valuable member of the team this dude
came here with no skill but how to lose
weight you know how to lose weight and
now he can edit cut some of the sizzles
you guys see cuts the reels cuts a lot
of the highlights cuts
um you know some of the the throwback
Clips does all of it and came here with
just an open mind I absolutely love this
kid George Harris come support him and
that is uh again January 7th that's a
Saturday the Commerce Casino
um keto George and Tall George are both
fighting on this and your boy will be
there to Corner them so I'm looking
forward to that man
shout out to the Georges George squared
they put a lot of work in so I'm looking
forward to see them do do some work it's
a spar star MMA SSP Fight Night 52.
Fight Night 52 they've had 52 of them
Commerce Casino and Commerce Casino
California I don't even know they have I
didn't know that City but that is lit
as far as Road dates uh your boys
getting some time off but uh first one
will be January 20th all right January
20th uh and 21st I'm in Tampa Tampa
Improv uh get your dust off those old
Mike alstott jerseys dust off those uh
Trent Dilfer jerseys go and bring back
that throwback Steve Young Buccaneers
jersey number eight and go ahead and get
your Tom Brady jerseys because your boys
come to Tampa Florida January 20th
through 21st Friday Saturday four shows
only this will sell out get your tickets
right now at thickboy.com and then
February I'm in Springfield Missouri
never been there looking forward to it
Naples Bakersfield Oklahoma City Tacoma
Atlanta Spokane it's all on there for
next year but for right now your boys
taking time off I'll be doing sets
around La and uh just working on things
man working cooking up I'm cooking I'm
cooking maybe I'm cooking but uh Tampa
you're up next January 20th through 21st
so looking forward to it thickboy.com if
you're looking for the perfect gift for
your men's or your mans or your woman's
or your grandma with the hairy lip you
can get you some uh Tire thick nectar
that award-winning thickness actors got
more Awards and then you can also get
the MLB quality authentic thick boy
jerseys we restocked those just time for
the holidays you get the military orange
you got the brown and yellow like the
Padres you got the hoodies to match the
hats to match we got it all thick
boy.com go get you some right now enjoy
the holidays enjoy your family those
parents out there doing uh Elf on the
Shelf good luck to you send me some more
ideas because I'm running out of
freaking ideas for these little bastards
all right love you guys thanks for
everything uh Thursday will be the best
of
um and also the thick Boy network award
show for fire of the Year thick boy of
the Year fight of the Year submission of
the Year knocked out of the Year we're
doing all that and we'll announce all
the winners on Thursday with a short
video next week we will be off but
um from everybody here at thick boy
thank you guys so much for liking
subscribing watch everything we do from
fight campaign food truck Fight Night
flashback the shop show all the other
shows that we do we love you guys and I
can't thank you enough for making this
very special year for me and the staff
so thank you to everybody out there
enjoy the holidays Merry Christmas Happy
Hanukkah let's bring in the new year
right all right January 1st 2023 is
coming in hot so thank you guys it's
been a great year unbelievable year one
of the best years of my life so I love
you guys and Tampa I will see you the
end of January and that's it thanks for
everything guys love you until next time
if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding